sex drugs possibly rock and roll we'll
find out
[Music]
pawnee today with joan callamezzo it's
kind of like the Meet the Press of our
town it's the big time Leslie yeah I
know it is I'm nervous I just wish I was
here on the different circumstances
guess who Megan Fox or the Desperate
Housewives
no joan callamezzo hey Jodie what's up
gorgeous good to see you comes on the
show all the time Joan loves him you
have the softest skin of any woman in
Pawnee I wish you could reach from your
TV screen and just touch your own skin
for a second you're pretty soft yourself
how are you kids doing they are pretty
good is it tough for them to have a
mother that is so beautiful
what's it like being the most attractive
woman in Pawnee you keep up those
funnies I'm gonna have to invite you
over for supper oh I'd first like to say
that I wasn't trying to advocate for
anyone I did not know that both of the
Penguins were males and I was just
trying to perform a cute fun ceremony to
promote our local zoo I have to say that
that stunt that you did with the
Penguins was clearly over the line now
Marshall what if anything can miss note
do to make it right
Joan we don't want to be unreasonable or
stop we think that she should separate
the Penguins annul the marriage
reimburse the taxpayers for the cost of
the wedding of course
and then resign oh is that it
that would do it anything else want me
to jump off a building perform Harry
Carey move to a different town no I kid
full of ideas here today let's take some
calls Joan why don't you okay caller are
you there yeah how can you justify
raising taxes for something they'll hurt
the town
I would just add to what Ben's
stammering about we aren't going to
raise taxes so that's that next caller
the ramsett park hugging story continues
with a shiny new twist ranger carl or
'the nur is here today now I understand
that you have a bombshell to drop that
you are just sitting on yes that's
correct
I came on today because I have some very
important information to share I finally
saw avatar and I thought it lived up to
the hype I'm not sure what that has to
do with the mugging but love Leslie
counterpoint I disagree with Carl okay I
have seen Avatar as well and I think it
exceeded the hype what oh boy
we disagreement the things are really
heating up in here aren't they
you should probably take some calls well
great okay good thank you next caller
you should resign hand repay your salary
okay - for resign thank you next caller
I just want to say that
soon when the zoo is really fun thank
you that's really sweet and I think you
should resign we received a tip that you
Leslie born and raised nope we're not
born in Pawnee
what gotcha
because you lied about it we cannot make
this a book club selection I was born in
Pawnee I'd stake my reputation on it
I have to tell you this feels like
gotcha journalism in what way that way
you put gotcha on my face I don't
understand why I'm on trial here
you should be grilling councilman Dex
hard oh you know what that's a really
good idea uh let's bring them out
councilman come on out hi sweetie
why don't you tell me he was gonna be
I've gotta be more exciting you look
great like I'm visible honey let's just
keep our private life in the bedroom
where it belongs we do not have a
private life stop saying that we have a
private life the fact is we never slept
together and if we did you would have
proof and we would have seen it by now
councilman I can prove it she has a mole
on her right buttock that is a total lie
you've never seen my butt what are you
talking about he has never seen my butt
well uh huh I guess it's your word
against his fine here Joan don't you
look for yourself
this happening wait there's no mole
there is no mole this exclusive story
there is no mole on Miss notes can't
believe it's come to this this is
utterly humiliating well councilman care
to make a comment about no mole gate yes
I really didn't think that there's no
could pull down her pants on TV
Jim Jim Kaepernick I know Jim Jim and I
have been to school together since we
were like three years old yes that's
true
do you remember when you peed your pants
in the second grade why did you bring
that up but I said yes suck your
underwear in your drawer and you got
really
garrison and the teacher came over and
pulled them out everybody called you the
gerbil because you always smelled like
soiled woodchips we forgot to say we're
on TV
yeah why should we trust this Ben Wyatt
guy because I'm trusting trust me I'm
trustworthy
and I am working very hard to make sure
that this town gets back on it here we
go okay great next caller so I looked
you up on Alta Vista and I found out
that the last seven times you've gone to
ended up bankrupt okay first of all why
does everyone in this town use Alta
Vista is it 1997 and second I am a
budget specialist I went to those towns
because they were bankrupt and now they
aren't and yeah I screwed up when I was
18 but who doesn't do dumb stuff when
they're 18 Joan stole my in gym teachers
husband so there you go well what else
you got collars boy once you wanna know
why we got married bring it I had no
prospects and Dougie here had an alcohol
problem but the Cold War was happening
and frankly we all thought we were gonna
die I figured I could really tick off my
parents by shacking up with some Pawnee
trash okay we all agree that marriages
have their ups and downs but at the end
of the day you're worth it because who
likes tap dancing I slept with Sharon in
1979 I used to get out of the shower in
front of your brother on purpose
hello again I'm Ron Swanson and I am
still taking your calls hopefully about
tonight's gala you're on the air hi
what's wrong with Joan she has a bad
hangover which she is pretending as
allergies okay wouldn't know never been
hungover after I've had too much whiskey
I cooked myself a large flank steak
pan-fried and salted butter I eat that
put on a pair of wet socks and go to
sleep
that works it
please call now if you have questions
about tonight's gala or one of my other
interests
woodworking novels about tall ships meet
that sort of thing
oh my goodness we are back with
America's greatest leader Annabel Porter
and her new favorite artisan local
woodworker Ron Swanson hello
I discovered Ron's chairs a few months
ago and what I absolutely love about a
Swanson is you can really use it for
anything yes mostly you use it for a
sitter make it a rustic accent piece in
your solarium even better use it as a
focal point in your yoga to put it by a
table and eat a meal we don't do meals
in my home know every two hours we eat
what I like to call a food tease like a
note wedge or a seaweed lozenge can I
just say and I think this is really
important so I need everyone to shut up
I love your hair oh thank you
it's genetic and unattainable
this is run go ahead call her hi my
Yorkshire Terrier has chewed up the legs
on my kitchen table is there a cheap way
to repair that great question
take a wall nut and rub it into the legs
of your table that'll mask the scratches
next thing you want to do is ditch
deteriorate your self a proper dog any
dog under fifty pounds is a cat and cats
are pointless come to the gala next
caller
grapes of wrath' chocolate chip ice
cream and Johnny Cash don't trust big
banks or small banks banks or Ponzi
schemes run by morons your house isn't
haunted
you're lonely whatever happened to hey I
have some apples would you like to buy
them yes thank you that's as complicated
as it should be to open a business in
this country
I've seen three movies in my life Bridge
on the River Kwai Patton and Herbie
fully loaded my girlfriend's kids love
it it's pretty funny next caller
[Music]
you